[Applause]
[Music]
I'm Christopher Hine and today we are
talking about the forms in Aikido
so I cuneiforms tend to be an obsession
point for most Aikido students and the
techniques inside the forms tend to be a
little less important and the overall
tactics and strategies of Aikido tend to
be even less important and so that's why
we have so much confusion in our system
in my approach to Aikido we kind of look
at it from the other way around which is
the strategy of I here the philosophy
and strategy is the first thing we look
at then we look at the tactics of Aikido
then we look at the techniques and then
we look at the forms last right so the
forms really are not that important
other than a way to collect and remember
all the techniques and the strategies
and the and the tactics of Aikido so
it's kind of more of a placeholder than
actually what's important so when people
think that the forms are the techniques
instead of just a collection of
techniques they think that IQ techniques
always have to end the way the forms end
and that means it has to end in a pin or
it has to end in a throw and that's
what's important is it ending in a pin
or it ending in a throw that's not at
all what's important generally what's
going to be important in Aikido is that
we can get to distance and make a safe
accord with someone right meaning the
real goal of Aikido is go hey hey let's
not have a struggle and then we don't
have a struggle that's ideally what I
want to do however when we get into
looking at the forms or looking at a
situation that keeps having problems
keeps having problems keeps having
problems now at the end of that is
actually our lowest percentage chance of
success so the end of the form is
actually the thing we want to do least
but most Aikido people and think that's
the thing we want to do most so today
we're gonna talk about the form of
yokomenuchi EDMA nage and how that
happens I'm gonna get Josh we're gonna
go to work Josh all right so we're gonna
talk about yokomenuchi eating me not
good and we're looking at that form and
under explaining all the little
techniques that are inside of the form
so a lot of times when people talk about
Aikido techniques and they're actually
talking about a form they say oh that
technique is very unlikely to happen but
the truth is the Aikido forms are built
of the same kind of techniques that
pretty much any other martial art would
use in that same context right so you
will see this
techniques that have appear in Filipino
martial arts the same techniques that
appear in Western European martial art
sites so all crime where arts that are
dealing with the same kind of context
which is basically some kind of weapon
context you will see the exact same
techniques Aikido puts them in forms so
they're easier to learn easier to
memorize and teach you a set of
strategic goals but you've got to
understand that that form is not what
you're actually going to do most the
time but you are gonna use all the
little techniques in this right so we're
gonna look right now at yokomenuchi
eating me noggin so let's switch
positions here all right so first of all
let's talk about what the attack is so
the yokomenuchi the oklahoma Nucci is
going to be someone coming forward with
an attack like this alright so again a
little a little out of the context of
this video but just to understand why
this might happen because that looks
silly yeah I had something anything in
my hand a knife a club a vase a frying
pan doesn't matter what I have in my
hand if I want to smash this guy in the
head in my hands over here I'm probably
gonna swing it like this right so if
there's a knife I'm gonna swing it like
that if I want to cut with the knife I'd
probably cut like this if I had a frying
pan right we're in the kitchen and I'm
upset I pick up my frying pan that's the
way I'm gonna smash this guy with it
right so that's what this big shot is
all about okay so I'm facing that
yokomenuchi and josh is coming in with
this so here he's coming in Bank all
right yeah what are my options with this
right I only really have a few options
now with the yokomenuchi because it
comes from one side and exits on the
other side moving just this way isn't
really gonna help me right so if I were
just to move this direction when he
swings that he's probably gonna hit me
here if I were just to move this
direction eventually he's probably gonna
hit me there so what I want to do is I
have to add a little bit of forward back
action right so if I wanted to move that
angle say when I did it I have to move
back when I do it right or if I want to
do this same thing or I could move
forward into it right so as he comes in
I can move forward right so this
position also will kind of help get me
out of that that that attacked his own
for him all right now what do I want to
do when I move well I don't want to just
stand there right I'm going to hit this
guy because hopefully that will end the
exchange so how do I do it I do it like
this bang
okay so this is already our second
technique our first technique is to
understand that a yokomen can be thrown
so that's the first technique in the
form second technique is one of the
options for this is to enter in and
smash this guy bang now what's really
nice about the way I'm hitting him is
notice the angle I'm taking so if I were
going to push this guy over right the
strongest jaw she is right now like this
is this way and this way the weakest he
is is right at this angle right so when
he comes in for that attack I'm stepping
right to that angle
now I'm shoving him boom that's what I
wanted you now I'm gonna hit him in the
face as hard as I can't find a weapon
which would be way better I'm gonna be
stabbing with that weapon are using it
and I hope that technique is useful in
of itself and if it was just useful and
successful it would look like this oh
okay
now that's man I hit that guy boom I
knocked him back fantastic that's what I
want then from there I would get to my
superior weapon platform or I would make
my escape depending if I'm gonna fight
I'm gonna fight with a weapon in my hand
because if this is a serious situation
I'm dealing with this seriously I'm not
gonna pretend box this guy right if I
could if I could not have to box this
guy then I'm gonna run away if I had to
box this guy well then it's serious
enough that I had to use a weapon right
so meaning I'm not gonna get into some
kind of ego battle where I'm like who
I'm gonna teach you a lesson my life or
the the lives of the people I love or is
in danger and so I'm gonna use a weapon
now so when that distance is created I'm
either getting to my weapon platform or
I'm getting out those are my two options
now that would be great if that
technique works successfully it would be
absolutely awesome what if it doesn't
now when that hand comes in and have you
switch sides for me actually so when
that hand comes in and I come to this
position very likely if this is a big
brute of a guy then I'm gonna hit him
and have zero effect so I hit him as
hard as I could I have zero effect if
this hand is unaccounted for it will
continue to come in and get me so I hit
him hard boom bully for me but he's a
brute he took that hit and I'm still
stabbed right or hit with a frying pan
or whatever it is right so as that as
that strike comes in I take that
position and this hand comes up so I'm
beginning to get suppression here now
this isn't enough because he can go
under my suppression well just like that
now if he has that knife in his hand let
me give him one
you guys can see he has that knife his
hand looks like this oh yeah my guts are
spilling out that's bad right I don't
want that so what's the next technique
we learned I learned to pass as it comes
down I pass it by now if you look at any
weapon based martial art you'll see the
same pass in Aikido it's called gate on
barrage which means the low sweep or low
pass in this it's because this kind of
attack is super common and I have to get
to this position so from here if he goes
low and I could track it I want to push
it away now notice the way I'm doing
that I'm trying to keep maximum distance
here I pull my body back as far as I can
you'll see lots of pictures of us you
but pulling your body back like this I
pull my body back like this and I'm
trying to skate it by then once it goes
by I didn't eat yo here right so see I
have elbow control right there so I'm
trying to keep that arm away from me
right so that's how I deal with that low
passing situation from here what do I
want to do well strategically I want to
get to the best position I can which is
here behind him this is the e DME
position now here I'm either gonna make
my escape or my my attack if if I'm
successful with this technique right
let's have you go ahead and switch to
the other side for me so here's the
first technique it's a yokomen ah that
happens right so I could either be using
that or have it used against me what's
my first defense it's this boom okay now
if he's not a big powerful guy that's
not successful he might pass if he
passes I pass low like that and get here
and assume a TV me position right now if
I could get to a superior weapon
platform I would boom boom bang right
I'm loading this guy up as quick as I
possibly can but it's something else I
could use buy it a knife or something I
could come down here with this guy right
so or if I need to make my escape with
an armed guy the only reasonable way to
escape is out the bats meaning I'm gonna
be escaping this way that gives me the
longest time to make my escape now what
if I'm trying to make the escape but
this guy's really on me so as I go he's
right on me right on me right on me like
that see what a bad position this is so
I can make my escape really bad or if
he's real tight to me like this and I go
for my weapon platform right he's up on
top of me I'm trying to get my weapon
can't do that so what I do is I end to
behind this guy I go like this this is
what I do now we're gonna be struggling
here right so I'm gonna try and pull him
off balance he's gonna try to get to me
and this is what leads to a classic
eating me nugget so as he's coming
around
around I come here I'm trying to drive
that guy back and that was an eating me
nuggets lots of ways that even mean I
get couldn't could come off but that's
just one of the examples now when you
look at that form
you think the objective of the form is
to get the EDM Onaga so in your brain
you're like the objective of this like
your technique is to make eating me
noggin in fact the oedema nugget was the
worst thing that could have happened in
that form that's the last thing I want
to do because all the other things I
would rather them have worked better
right I would rather have hit him with
the yokomen before he'd hit me with the
yokomen I would rather have stopped him
when he threw the yokomen I would rather
have passed it and got to a successful
weapon platform or to made an escape but
none of those things happen because this
guy's on it on it on it so when we get
to the end of the form that's the last
thing I have to do it's also the lowest
percentage thing I could do so when I
feel people are thinking about what
they're going to do in Aikido they're
generally thinking about doing the
lowest percentage thing possible the
highest percentage thing possible is to
stay at distance and keep that guy from
ever attacking you which is the main
idea of Aikido but we've made all these
failures in the end we have to have some
technique to help us the technique is
not the form though and the form is not
the technique to two different entities
all right so this is the technical
breakdown for yokomenuchi
et managua
[Music]